rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message being
determined to win
over to you Les Brown I went to the next
floor necessary to stop talking to
people and seeking and asking for what I
wanted and leveraging relationships and
trying to find out how do the people do
it that went ahead of me how do they do
it and then what is it I need to do how
is it I need to train myself to develop
myself
what's the resources that will be
required in order to make it happen and
as I start seeking out and asking
questions I started running into people
said I know someone who can help you do
that and they helped me get connected
with those people remember we have so
much energy that can take us so far it's
necessary that you hook up with some
other energy that can take you to the
next level I hooked up willingness
unless let's go I said away we go
[Applause]
[Music]
and guess what here we are
I love it you want your stuff it's
necessary you take responsibility for
now you make it happen
that you don't give up that you don't
take any objection or disappointment or
defeats personally that you keep on
keeping on that you don't decide that I
can't make it because you can't see the
light at the end of the tunnel that you
realize that the part of the program and
here's something you've got to resolve
say this to yourself every day so as
long as you breathing you got a shot at
your dream that's the way I resolve say
this please it's not over until I win
you've got that right
[Applause]
not over till I win not over til I get
through it's not over til I get over not
over till I get what I want y'all can't
open a day to look out I'm gonna come
back and take the hinges off that's
that's how you got to do that you've got
to have that kind of courage that type
of determination if you want to make it
happen it's you that you've got to take
personal responsibility to make it
happen it's not over until I win it's
not over until I win it's not over until
I win I would say it's not over ever
ever it's just not over how sad is that
when it's over like you never win it's a
constant battle it's a constant grind
and yet you're always winning because
the race is the one in the progress is
the wind the journey is the wind it's
never over
I think embracing that attitude is
really healthy that idea of emptying the
ocean with a ladle like Buddha said you
wake up when you do something impossible
you're working towards an impossible
goal as soon as you have a goal that is
achievable and then you hit that goal
what happens you get sad it's like a
moment like yeah we hit it as soon as
you feel like you can hit it for me even
not even hitting it you know for me it
was hitting a million YouTube
subscribers by the time this video comes
out with probably they're just knowing
that I could hit it that's it I checked
that it's like it's not like it's so
important I don't even care about
celebrating Dominion anymore because I
knew it was gonna happen as soon as you
know you're gonna hit a goal whether you
achieve it yet or not at least for me
you lose interest I lose interest so I'm
not passionate about that goal anymore
so you got to set a bigger goal those
what happens if you don't have a bigger
goal to shoot or it's something else
it's gonna you know motivate you then
you get depressed you get sad you get
down don't know what to do so it's never
over there is no retirement why do you
want to retire like why even think about
retirement why do you want to retire if
you love what you're doing why would you
ever want to take a break from it would
you ever want to cancel it and just sit
on the beach all day if you want to
escape and sit down the beach is good
you hate your life and so the answer is
not go sit on the beaches do something
more meaningful now the answer is not
save up years of money to get the 65
that you can retire and then go live in
some resort
community for the rest of your life and
be bored let's do something meaningful
now you have the opportunity take charge
of your life and change it I got asked a
question recently where somebody said if
you had an extra hour in your day what
would you do and other people were
answering when I would sleep more I
would go hiking more I would you know
figure out whatever they want to do more
I hate that question what would I do
more I would do more of what I'm doing I
love the time couldn't spend it I
wouldn't sleep more if I wanted to see
more I would just sleep more I wanted to
go hiking more I would do that like I
don't agree with the premise of the
question because it assumes that I'm not
doing work that I'm already excited
about now it's like I don't need an
extra hour in my being able to be
fulfilled so now suddenly I can go out
and do the things that I want to do I
take responsibility right like you're
delegating responsibility to some other
force that if I had 25 hours then I
would do something special with my life
just watch me
know your money if you had 25 hours in a
day you'd be in the same rut you are
right now period it's really when you
take responsibility for the resources
that you have and say 24 is what I got
is what everybody got is what Steve Jobs
has and Howard Schultz and Evan
Carmichael Oprah Winfrey everybody got
the same 24 the difference is how you
use it is it being used and the
fulfilling link to you the people who
just wish they had an extra hour would
waste it they'd squander it they
wouldn't find a practical way to apply
it guarantee you it's a constant that if
you had a new planet Earth 2 and you put
everybody on there and everybody starts
with the same amount of money right the
same amount of success or whoever you
wanted to find it within a short amount
of time the same dynamics could play out
the same people had money here would
have money there people had success here
would have success there it's not
because they're taking advantage or
they're screwing people over they just
think differently they have a different
mindset they're choosing positivity
they're more determined to win and the
people had the negative baggage who felt
like they couldn't do things we're just
complaining we're blaming lack of
resources and everything else they would
end up losing again this is a constant
it doesn't matter what you start with it
matters about your mindset and your
motivation and your attitude the people
who you look up to the most the people
on the wall behind me
the
people who are the heroes of your career
that said if I could be something like
that that'd be amazing if I can have
that kind of level impact if I could
touch people like Oprah okay the people
that you look up to the most had nothing
it's not about what you start with if
you take the money and resources away
from all the most successful people they
would get it back again because of their
mindset because they're determined stop
blaming the lack of resources it doesn't
make a difference stop blaming your lack
of the 25th hour doesn't make a
difference
there was no retirement period enjoy
your work I challenge the youtuber to
make a video a day for 30 days she was
she wants a girl her channel for those
youtubers I would say if you want to
grow your channel go daily daily content
10-minute videos she was making my 4 to
5 minute videos a couple times a week go
daily go 10 minutes do that consistently
do that for 30 days she's getting closer
to the end of the 30 days until they're
great now just keep it up she's like
what for how long forever like you just
keep going there's no end date you just
keep going video add a 10 minutes plus
just keep going find a way to make it
work like there is no end date on this
stuff guys there's no magical like I'm
gonna sell my company and then I'm gonna
go retire the rest of my life like enjoy
the work you will not be happy when you
sell your business you're gonna want to
do something else and so if you look at
the most successful people they enjoy
the climb they enjoy seeing that
mountain and starting to climb up that
mountain they enjoy the journey it's not
just about hitting some goal there is no
retirement there is no end date is just
forever and ever and ever and ever and
when you do something that you love
that's amazing like imagine being in
love with your husband or wife forever
and ever and ever now why would you ever
want to give that up it's a retirement
from that dosnt retirement from I'm a
amazing marriage there's a retirement
from an amazing child relationship like
I don't want to ever retire from Nina
ever retire from Hayden I love them I
love my life with them I want that to be
forever I love my business the same way
I love you guys I love the impact
that's forever never ever ever ever ever
ever ending it may not be YouTube always
may be something else but you take the
belief out of me that's it it's game
over
and I hope you find the thing that you
are so determined to keep going that you
never want to quit so the question today
today is I want you to be consistent and
I'm curious what is that thing that you
can commit to doing every day you know
for me it's believing in people right
what is it for you what is the thing
that I never want to give up even
somebody's like here's here's a hundred
million dollars you can never do this
again say no what do you turn down 100
million dollars for what would you turn
down 100 million dollars for let me know
leave that in the comments below super
curious if I know I also want to give a
quick shout out to Josh to our earthly
Joshua thank you so much for picking up
cop in my book your one word it really
really means a lot to me and I hope you
enjoyed it so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you and I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events best
[Music]
has there never been a point where you
have felt frustration sort of in
Hollywood absolutely but you know what
you run into stupid people everywhere
unfortunately doesn't matter if it's the
cab driver who doesn't want to stop for
you or you know or go past 110th Street
or you know or you know if it's if it's
some executive who somehow managed to
become in a position of power to
greenlight movies who has no clue I mean
you know some things are just timing and
and determination and perseverance
anything you're gonna do yet you know
when I wanted to become an actor and
start making movies it was the same kind
of determination the same kind of thing
where you're like you make a decision
and you're like I know this is gonna be
difficult I know it's not gonna be the
easiest thing in the world but I'm
determined to do it and I really care
I'm really caring about this decision so
you just make it a priority and you know
when anyone's starting out in any
business or any sort of life endeavor or
any sort of relationship you're starting
out with the intention to go all the way
and to me was just a decision and I just
made a commitment to sticking to it then
another important factor is
determination and you should not think
the CDs development can take place
within a few days or few years we must
understand you see the day's development
even may take eons
says they are determination if you boot
Evie I thought they'd consider as a
Buddhist and and want to really practice
buddhadharma the right from the
beginning you must lessee make up your
mind or doesn't matter even may take
millions of bills builds of eons city
the what's a day after all what is the
purpose of her life the meaning of
existence nothing you realize something
positive then even you see there is and
man told you it is meaningful if you're
really wasting our life that was our
life then even one day too long so once
is you determined once you make up your
mind some kind of firm determination and
clear and then time is not important so
they like each other diverse you are one
of you see there there so long stays
with me stone on sentient beings
suffering remain I will be in order to
self there's a death sentence resilience
it gives me something to intercept and
all by the inside so the more for them
is the impatience and si minister before
you city
I want something the quickest on that's
or something then I can reserve also
police tactic the cheapest method
quickest cheapest method result will be
poorest so is it that cycle wrong so
that I would like to share with you so
that's why is it
I myself all dirty recite is to some
mantra boys do some visualization is a
certain mandalas but mine in my daily
practice although my practice very poor
very poor
but even then see there I'm iris a main
emphasis on this form over tooth and put
the children and Karuna
so that really I feel it is something
relevant then through these practice you
will get something practical benefit
realize a huge big deities sometimes I
think the keeping oneself almost almost
is like the gt1 self-deceiving once you
see one oneself so therefore I think we
must do subtractors step by step with
patience with the determination once you
involve or dedicated or determine
practice then some improvement you can
see as a year by your decayed by at
least decayed by decade then you can see
or at least the sound change some some
improvement you can see once you once
you see that that also gives you gives
you some kind of encouragement
so she change raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion and not
one drop of myself work depends on your
it's suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details